زعيم كوريا الشماليه شدد على ضروره مضاعفه
بلاده لقدراتها مؤكدا ان المهمه الاساسيه
لقواته المسلحه النوويه تتمثل بكبح احتمال
اندلاع الحرب وحمايه الاستقرار اما ثنيها
فمهم غير دفاعيه في حال فشلت طبعا الاولى
وهذا هو السبب وفقاكم جونج اون وراى طرح
مهمه تصميم وانت صاروخ باليس جديد عابر
للقارات ويسمح بشن ضربه نوويه انتقاميه
على الفور في حاله وقوعه هجوم كم اكد كذلك
ان هيكل العلاقات الدوليه قد تحول الى
نظام الحرب البارده الجديده لافتا الى
تسريع وتيره مواصفه بالدفع نحو التعدديه
القطبيه الجنوبيه جاء سريعا حيث حذرت من
نهايه نظام جارتها الشماليه في حال قيامها
باي محاوله نوويه حتى على الوقف الفوري
لتطوير قوتها النوويه والعوده الى مساري
نزع السلاح النووي سيول شدت على بناء
اشيلها لوضعيه الاستعداد العسكري للرد على
اي استفزازات بالاعتماد على نظام ثلاثي
المحاور اي منصه الضربه الوقائيه والعقاب
الهائل والانتقام الكوري وهو برنامج
لاستهداف قياده الخصم في حاله الطوارئ
[موسيقى]